hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
it's Thursday so it's time for another
episode of Theory Thursdays
congratulations to last week's winner
theory number five Leonardo with his
theory on how Avengers in game is going
to play out Congrats Leonardo you are
now in the pool of champions and
tomorrow I'll do a video where you can
all vote for which theory was your
favorite for February as for this week
we have some really great theories
different than we've heard in the past
so I'm really excited to talk about them
if you're new to Theory Thursdays it's
my new segment where you all submit your
theories to me I choose 5 MVP and you
all vote on which one is your favorite
each week we will have one winner and at
the end of the month you will vote on
which winners theory you thought was
your favorite
the overall winner wins the month and
the monthly prize which is currently two
imax tickets so you can go see Avengers
in game in IMAX if you'd like to submit
a theory for your chance to end up an
episode you can find the instructions
down in the description below just a
heads up I got a lot of theories this
week for Captain Marvel I did not choose
any so there would be no spoilers for
anybody who has not seen the movie yet
alright so let's get started with some
theories theory number one this week
comes from Kevin Pugh and Kevin says
remember the scene at the end of the
first guardians of the galaxy movie star
Lord needed the help of all the other
guardians to wield the Power Stone
without dying we keep seeing theories of
other Avengers wildung the gauntlet to
undo the snap what if Avengers endgame
has a similar ending to the Guardians 1
but instead we see each original Avenger
using a stone to defeat Thanos but the
power sent each of the Avengers to a
different fate
Captain America using the time stone
gets sent back to the past and Bucky
becomes the new Captain America hawkeye
using the reality stone sends him to an
alternate reality to be reunited with
his family
iron man using the mine stone Tony
retires but unlocks the mutant gene and
goes off to investigate Hulk
wielding the space stone gets
transported and disappears he may return
in later movies Thor wields the power
stone and is unaffected physically but
feels the weight of being ruler of
Asgard and leaves and Kevin's theory
states that black widow will die in the
movie during rising action this theory
is certainly thinking outside of the box
which is one thing I really like about
it Kevin is right when
he says that the Avengers cannot wield
the power of the Infinity stones they're
not strong enough and when I think of
the guardians of the galaxy scene I
think of what Steve Rogers has said in
the past about the Avengers doing
everything together and having the
stones affect each Avenger in a personal
way would be a really cool twist so I
can definitely see this theory playing
out on the big screen so that does it
for theory number one on to theory
number two theory number two comes from
j GF and j GF has a theory about the
bracelets all of the Avengers are
wearing in the league set photos
JGF theory is that these bracelets are
actually used to hold any of the various
Infinity stones when or if the Avengers
get them if the Avengers are traveling
through the quantum realm collecting the
Infinity stones they will need something
to hold on to them as the only people
with the power to do so are Captain
Marvel and Thor we know that mortals can
hold on to an infinity stone except they
just need something strong enough to
contain its power now rocket Bruce Tony
Scott and nebula would be able to design
these bracelets because they have all
been in contact with the Infinity stones
whether in the past or they have some
sort of extensive knowledge speaking
about the cube the orb and the scepter
so when they all put their minds
together they will be able to create
these bracelets to hold the Infinity
stones
the reason JGF thinks they are not used
for travelling inside of the quantum
realm is because hank pym didn't use any
sort of bracelet like that when he went
in there and also the avengers already
have a suit to travel so creating two
different things just to go into the
quantum realm is a bit much so JGF
thinks that Tony Bruce Scott rocket and
nebula will build these bracelets we've
all seen in the leaked photos in order
for them to hold on to the collected
Infinity stones this certainly makes a
lot of sense especially if the Avengers
are going back in time to collect the
Infinity stones it's true they can't
hold on to them themselves they'll need
some sort of container and the Avengers
do have some knowledge about the
Infinity stones and a lot of the
Avengers are really really smart so they
could definitely design a device capable
of holding an infinity stone and like
JGF said they already have the suits
ant-man already has the technology to
travel inside of the quantum realm I
would not be surprised if this theory
ends up being true for Avengers in game
so that does it for theory number two on
to theory number three theory 3 comes
from Brandon
with a theory on what happened to Cherie
after Avengers infinity war Brandon says
as we know nokia was not an infinity war
with Shuri Ikoyi and the wakandan army
in Captain America's Avengers team due
to her being on a secret mission of
course we know Ikoyi survived the snap
and we have yet to learn about Shuri
until Avengers end game comes out it
says that she died in the trailer but
this could be misdirection from the
Russo brothers if sure he did survive
maybe both her and Ikoyi could be
searching for Nakia find her and inform
her on what has happened to T'Challa and
ask her to come back to what Conda so
they can help the Avengers defeat Thanos
I find this interesting because I kind
of don't believe that Shari is dead I
think this was misdirection from the
Russo brothers in the Avengers in-game
trailer and it wouldn't make sense for
Shuri to go off and search for Nakia to
find out whether or not she survived the
snap we do know Nakia went on a secret
mission and maybe that mission could be
really important for avengers endgame is
definitely something to think about
because I do not think that Sheree is
dead so that's it for theory number
three on to number four number four
comes from Jeff Exodus and Jeff believes
that Loki is still alive Jeff says I
believe Loki used his illusions and what
Thanos actually broke was the neck of
one of the already dead as guardians
lying around the ship Loki has never
made a direct and obvious straight-on
attack on anybody it seems idiotic that
he would falter from this
self-preservation against the mad Titan
wearing the space and the Power Stone
Jeff believes that the line spoken by
Thanos no resurrections this time was
needed in order for the surprise and
suspense of Loki's outcome to be there
after all the previous so-called deaths
so the question is how did Loki and
Valkyrie who was also missing get away
Jeff says that if you pay attention to
the end of thor ragnarok there is a
quick scene that shows the outer hull of
the Asgardian ship they used to escape
Ragnarok and like a homogeneous trikes
back where the Millennium Falcon
attaches to the Star Destroyer the
grandmasters personal ship is attached
to the outer hull just like Valkyrie it
is missing an Infinity Ward nor is there
anything in the wreckage resembling it
there's a good chance that that's how
they escaped while Thanos was
concentrating on killing a fake Loki
this is a very interesting theory mainly
because I am one of the people who
believes that Loki isn't actually dead
and
makes an excellent point when he says
that Loki has never attacked anybody
like that before and if you do think
about it it is idiotic on Loki's part he
knows who thinness is he knows how
strong he is he knows what the Infinity
stones are and he knows that Thanos has
two of them why would he attack Thanos I
always thought that it was an illusion
but I never thought that it could be one
of the already dead as Guardians that
Loki switched it makes a lot of sense
and could quite possibly be what
actually happened so that's theory
number four on to the final theory
number five theory number five comes
from Nick gorilla and his theory is that
Thanos never left Earth Nick thinks that
Thanos is still in Wakanda Nick says
after re-watching Avengers infinity war
I noticed something at the end of the
film when Thanos walks out of his hut to
the right you can see what looks like
flamingos then in the trailer you see
him brush against what looks like the
kiwano fruit flamingos and kiwano fruit
are both native to Africa also the
kicker to this is that he looks at the
sunset and size while Conda is known for
its beautiful sunsets this is a pretty
well thought-out theory and good catch
one of the screenwriters has said that
Thanos is on Titan too but again there
is so much misdirection when it comes to
what they want us to see and know about
this movie and we've seen leaks where
fan OHS is on earth at the avengers
headquarters fighting The Avengers and
in the in-game Super Bowl TV spot we see
Thor in a place that kind of looks like
Wakanda perhaps Thanos is in Wakanda and
Thor went searching for him again I
would not be surprised if we saw this
happen in Avengers end game so that does
it for all this week's theories let's do
a quick recap theory number one was that
the Avengers will each hold an infinity
stone to defeat Thanos and each stone
will give each avenger a different fate
such as Captain America being flung back
in time theory number two was about the
bracelets that we've seen in the leaked
photos being used to hold Infinity
stones when the Avengers travel through
the quantum realm Theory number three is
that shereé is actually alive and she
went to search for Nakia to help the
Avengers theory number four is that Loki
is still alive and him and Valkyrie
escaped on the Grand Master ship and
Theory number five is that Thanos is
actually in Wakanda and not off planet
so those are this week's theories be
sure to vote on which one you thought
was your favorite and again if you would
like to submit your own theory for a
chance to end up on Theory Thursdays you
can find the email to send them to in
the directions in the description down
below be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
theories and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to marvel and
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you